Now let's consider the case
where an object is undergoing
circular motion, but
in this motion let's
again introduce our polar
coordinate system, r-hat
and theta-hat.
We now want to consider the
case where d theta dt is not
constant.
And what does that mean?
That means that if d theta
dt is positive, for instance,
the object is speeding
up in this direction,
or if d theta dt is
negative, the object
is slowing down
in this direction.
That's one type of case.
So in this instant,
we always know
that there is the radial
component at any instant given
by minus r d theta dt squared.
But because it's speeding
up and slowing down,
there is now a non-zero
tangential component
to the acceleration.
Let's see where that comes from.
So again, if we write our
velocity vector as r d theta dt
theta-hat, this is the
product of two terms.
And because it's a
product of two terms,
we need the product
rule from calculus
in when we take a derivative.
So the derivative
will be the derivative
of the first term
times the second term
plus the first term times the
derivative of the second term.
Now we've already
analyzed this piece
and this was precisely
minus r d theta dt
quantity squared r-hat.
That was the always the
non-zero radial acceleration.
But now let's analyze
this piece separately.
r, for our circular
motion, is a constant.
So it's only d theta dt
that is no longer constant.
So we simply take a
second derivative.
And so we get r times d squared
theta dt squared theta-hat.
And that is our acceleration.
Notice that it has
two components.
We'll write the first
component, a theta,
that's its tangential
component, theta-hat
plus the radial component ar.
That's again, the component.
And because this
is a vector, r-hat
where the a theta is now the
second derivative of d theta
squared dt squared.
And just to remind you that ar
is minus ar d theta dt squared.
So when d squared theta
dt squared is positive,
it means d theta
dt is increasing.
And so if this object is going
in this clockwise direction,
we call that speeding up.
In a similar fashion,
it's easy to understand
that when d squared theta
dt squared is negative,
then d theta dt is decreasing.
And so it can be slowing down.
Or if it slows
down and stops, it
can start to move in
the other direction.
So again, the acceleration
has two components,
a tangential component,
and that depends
on the type of circular
motion we're talking about,
whether d theta dt
is constant or not.
It always has a non-zero
inward radial component
given by the component
minus r d theta dt squared,
regardless of whether it's
speeding up or slowing down.